تعد الألواح الشمسية طريقة شائعة
لالتقاط الطاقة المتجددة ولكن لها
بعض القيود فهي تحتاج إلى الكثير من
التثبيت الخاص بالمساحة ولها بعض
العيوب الجمالية ولكن ماذا لو
بدت هكذا وكل نافذة من
حولك تتضاعف كلوحة شمسية قمنا
بتطوير طريقة  لجعل الخلايا الشمسية
شفافة من خلال التقاط
الضوء غير المرئي فقط ، فهذه هي
التقنية الوحيدة التي تتيح لك القيام بهذه
الطاقة في كل مكان ليست هي الأولى في
تطوير الزجاج الشمسي ، وقد توصل آخرون إلى
نتائج من خلال الجمع بين الزجاج
والخلايا الشمسية التي تكون أرق وأصغر.
يمكن أن يكون لها عيوب مثل انخفاض
كفاءة الطاقة وشفافية أقل في
كل مكان ، اتخذ نهجًا مختلفًا
وطور طلاءًا شمسيًا مصنوعًا من
الأصباغ العضوية المصممة لتتناسب مع
شفافية النوافذ القياسية ،
توجد أصباغ ممتصة للضوء في كل مكان حولنا ،
إنها في دهانات ، إنها في أصباغ
بالنسبة للملابس ، ما فعلناه هو أننا
صممنا تلك الأصباغ
لامتصاص ضوء الأشعة تحت الحمراء بشكل انتقائي وأيضًا التعاون  قم بتحويل
هذا الضوء إلى كهرباء وهذا هو
المفتاح لأن ضوء الأشعة تحت الحمراء غير مرئي
للعين البشرية يمكنك أن ترى أن
الضوء المرئي لا يفعل أي شيء
يمر عبر الزجاج
بينما يبدأ ضوء الأشعة تحت الحمراء غير المرئي
في توليد الكهرباء ،
النتيجة التي يقولها الفريق  هو الزجاج الشمسي الذي
يوفر أفضل مزيج من
كفاءة الطاقة والشفافية ، وقد
بدأنا في تركيب
زجاجنا في المباني الحقيقية ، والتركيب
هنا هو أحد التركيبات
الأولى لهذا الزجاج ، فنحن نتحكم في
الجهد هنا على سبيل المثال لتشغيل
الإضاءة  في الغرفة في الوقت الحالي ،
لا يزال الزجاج الشمسي أقل كفاءة من
الألواح الشمسية التقليدية ، لكن إمكانية
استخدامه على نطاق أوسع لا يمكن أن تعوض عن ذلك
تأمل الشركة في أن
تكمل تقنيتها الألواح الشمسية التقليدية التي
تجمع بين تقنيات الطاقة المتجددة هذه
ويمكن أن تصل المباني إلى صافي
الصفر  الطاقة مما يعني أنها تنتج قدرًا من
الطاقة بقدر ما تستهلك ، نرى حقًا
مستقبل هذه الشركة المصرية للاتصالات  علم الأنساب الذي يتم
تطبيقه في كل مكان تكون فيه طاقة الشمس
حولنا في كل مكان ،
فلماذا لا يتم تحويلها إلى كهرباء